well March is colorectal cancer
awareness month and one of the main you
know causes of the disease is lifestyle
choices and here to show us how changes
of what we eat can help prevention is
blog on a registered dietitian
Abby Sharpe good morning to you yes so
let's talk about colorectal cancer and
some ways that we can prevent it I see
we got a lot of great foods here we do
so you know a study conducted by the
dairy farmers of Canada found that most
Canadians are not thinking about colon
cancer top of mind we think about lung
cancer we think about breast cancer but
this is the second leading cause of
cancer related deaths in Canada 68
Canadians are diagnosed every day and
4,200 women
4900 men die every single year big big
numbers here that's amazing I just saw
with over 22,000 people a year hearing
it it's it's staggering but you know the
good news is we can do something about
it
90% of cases are curable with some early
detection strategies and it really comes
down to baking some basic lifestyle
changes to help reduce your risk so
things like not smoking exercise
managing your weight getting that early
screening and of course a diet filled
with lots of fruits and vegetables whole
grains and milk products oh my goodness
right well I tell you when it comes to
create awareness it all starts with the
diet that is so important it's so
important and my concern is a dietitian
is that two to three Canadians are not
getting enough of the recommended milk
servings to be able to help reduce that
risk so this is what this is all about
you know milk we know is loaded with
calcium it's got vitamin D and studies
are suggesting that those nutrients may
help reduce your risk of colon cancer so
we really want to focus on getting those
two to two to four servings every day so
where we make it here for breakfast this
morning yes so I thought we'd do a
little oatmeal with apples and dates
it's one of my favorite recipes to get
the get the day started so we've got
some large flake rolled oats and I like
the large flake because they're a little
bit like the texture a little bit better
okay they do take a little longer to
cook so I like to start them the night
before and what I'm gonna do is just pop
this into a little bowl here
some flax seed which has got some fiber
lots of fiber yes the flax seed mm-hmm
and fibers also linked to a reduced risk
of colon cancer so we want to get our
fiber rich foods in as well like I've
got some whole grains here we've got
some pulses and beans and legumes and of
course our fruits and vegetables as well
so in there we go I'm also going to add
my water everything's gonna go into the
fridge water and our secret ingredients
are milk sixteen essential nutrients
going in right there so this is what's
you know this is the key ingredient so
this sets up in the fridge overnight and
then the next day we pop it on the stove
I've got one ready to go and you just
heat this on like a nice medium heat for
about 15 minutes till it all comes
together I'm gonna add in my dates which
we love dates the natural sweetener I
love this stuff I love the chewiness too
it's a great texture and some dried
apple in there as well and so basically
I'm just gonna let that simmer for about
15 minutes and then in the end I would
add in a little bit of brown sugar and
I'm gonna finish this off we've got some
here ready to go a little bit of chopped
almonds for crunch so good so you see
I'm in stop smiling you can get this
recipe and get enough dot CA and while
you're there you can check out the get
enough help her up it's this great
downloadable app it's totally free to
download at the App Store or Google Play
and it was developed by registered
dietitians at the dairy farms of Canada
to help Canadians get enough of the
recommended servings from Canada's Food
Guide of the different food groups and
you'll find all these kinds of recipes
right on the get enough help her out
well I can feel the passion of making
this the awareness known to people out
there I mean I'm really thankful that
you came by here today because so wait
what I want to ask you about this what
is this right here I know right so this
is our spiced chia pudding so here how
chia pudding before I've had no oh well
you're gonna love this you're gonna want
to try this recipe so basically all it
is is a little bit of milk we've heated
with some honey and some nice baking
spices I've put it out of the chia seeds
and the chia seeds kind of
all that moisture in the fridge
overnight and thickens into like a
pudding like consistency and then we
asked some yogurt the next day you're
like thrilling you're like oh
feed me I know so really excited about
that you can get that at get enough
dossier on the app as well you know what
there's so much a wealth of information
here and everybody remember what she
said it starts from what you eat and you
become what you eat and it's so
important and heavy thank you so much
for joining